nous sommes le 23 août 1944 trois
soldats Français trouvent la mort face
au troupes allemandes à la verrière de
jour avant la libération cet homme était
au premier rang au volant d'une des
jeeps du peloton de reconnaissance comme
peloton de reconnaissance il fallait
aller se faire tirer dessus pour savoir
d'où partait les coups ce qu'on a fait
notre le premier peloton est resté à
Voisins Bretonneux il a eu un combat à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux et nous nous
sommes venus ici et nous nous sommes
fait à l’humés qu'on disait comme on dit
dans notre jargon deux jours plus tard
le régiment rallier la Porte de
Saint-Cloud sous les acclamations
jean-pietri en garde un souvenir
contrasté
Vichy un souvenir de
l'Autriche c'était vraiment triste de
voir la façon dont on
a été détruit mais à genoux de Paris non
c'était je dis pas que c'était d'oublier
mais presque on a traversé Versailles au
milieu des cris des bouquets de fleurs
et des bises des demoiselles et des
dames cette commémoration est organisée
chaque année par les communes du
Mesnil-Saint-Denis de Coignières et de
la verrière ainsi que par l'amicale des
anciens combattants de ces trois villes